S LARGELOR
LAST WEEK.
VOTES ARE BEG COUN
LE HANGING
ON BY
ARIZONA HOUSBOWERS LOST AS WELL.
ED TTUT
STANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE.
THE LATESTT IS SOMNE
ON'TY
HOUSE
SPVOSS
REFUSINME TWOYEARS LATER TO DEN
WI
DEATRINO SPEAKER
HOUSE, ROBINOST .
IN OTHER WORDS, IT WAS OKAY TO
E T LET  WWON'T LET
EM AN. WAS AKINDF ON BOARDF TRYD
AUD, BUT HE JUST DIDN'T
VOS, HE'S NOT US TRUMPE QUITE CL
ONCE AND HAD A PRETTY GOODI
WOULD CALL I ALLIANCE.PERS. LAU
INSTEAD OF TAKING THE PATHT
YOU'VE SEEN OTR NT THEE ABOUT T
FROM TONTHS
INCLUDING N JUNE
O OVERTURN THEOF THE ELECTION A.
HE SAID IT WAS UNCONSTITUT
THERE WAS NOTHING FOR HIM TO
TRUMP ADMITTED PY HE DID
T KNS OPPONENTHIS ENDORSED VERY
BACAM GOING
HIM IF VOS DOESN'T DWH
WANT HIM TO.
E WEEKAGO,DSEY GRAHAM TELLING T
DENIALFFCH
NOT HAPPEDWEEK I
STILRUNNING.
LY PUT OUT
D , DI CHE
A TOURING  IN TH
SAYING T W BASICAL
FRRUMP IS THE REASON WHY HE IST
>> I THINKSEPLE, NOTE
THINK TH ON THE
HILL ABO TION LIE AND E IMPAT T
LYN JANUARY 6th, BUT
GENEMS THIS
ITONE LIKEARI  WHA
A MOCRATT THEIR  IF
SENATORSOR ON RMT NOW ATREG TOT
PASSEFO ENSURE THAT
>> ONETHT COER ANDOU DON'T INTE
RUBN NOMINEE IS WHO I024 AND .N
OF STATE IS
HEL ONANh.EA LITT.
HE'S IDENTIFIED HIMSELF
.
CEANONNF
TI
OVERLERE
HE'S STI PO DECERTIFY
THE 2020 IN
YOU'VE GOT CARE RI
FOLKS
RUNNING ON THIS STUFF.
HEN THATE WERE N TH
REPUBLICAS DO WANT NUE  THEIE.O.
THEY ARE VERSSISTRUMP'S.ON WE'RT
THET AN DEMOCRATS
THE CONVENTION WISDO
COMPARED TO THINGS LIKFLATIO T
ARE FEELING ARTO BE TANT TN  ID
DES AND CLEA ON AN. WILL E
ELECTION, ER,
VOTERS RESPONDO ARGUMES ?L SEE I
DEMOCRATS CAMPAIGN.
ARE THEYAMY OR AREEYT VOTE WIT ?
>> OAPS ALL OF THE
>> REALLTTER IS THE QUESTION I
MYSELF W EG SEEMS TO
STEMM WHERE PELE LY.
I LLPOM
ARIZONA, FROM
SIN AND YOU DO
SEE THAT THE DC
CANDIDAT ARE UP IN THE EARLY
DITESE T.'S NOTTI
ABOUT THE 2020 T
RE PERHAPS A
LITTLE BIT ME THAN
WET EXACLLO EVEN
WHAT'S GOING ON NATIIT
>> WHEN IT COMINGS TO THETARIE C
POWER
EVERYONE THINKS, THE STATE
ES ARE THE ONES
MAKE T LT THAT
STATE'S ELECTION IS GOING TO IK.
OF STATE IN A
STEAD YOU O MUCH
SIER HOW AN
ELECTION IS NDOUF HOW THE RESOU.
YO INVESTIGATIONS TO QUESTION EN
VOTERS.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S
SOMETHING I'M GOINTOHING COME N
SIGNIFICANT PART OF WHAT
THIS LOOKS LIKE NO
WE ECE
MARK IN ARIZONA HAS  S
EN 202, UMD
>> WE'RE AE QUESTIONABVOTERSAR
QUESTIONS HERE WHAT IS GOE REPU
PARTY WHEN IT COMES TO
HEREAPPENINGE POLITICAL ACTION H
OMIN  THEVIKTOR ORBAN WHO IEWAUC
>> I'MERL YO W
SHOULDTEOR S  THE JUDRIN THE WOR
ERT CAN
SAVE THE REST FROM GOINGISTS CA
HELL.
I HAVE COME  T HUGE S HAS REAL
DISDAIN FOR DEMOY,ETNG AT
POLITICAL CONFERENCE.
>> THE SCHOLARS WILL TEL LEADINO
WHERE A FIGURE LIKE THIS IS ABLE
ET ELECT OG IS FAV S
ESSEIMPOSS F
N TION
WE SEE, IF WE DIDN'T KNOW IT
WA THAT THIS IS THE CLEAR  OLOTE
'SG THS.CTION ON BEHALF OE
THT EYBA
SPEAK AT C